by the nuggets having some troubles here
three to shoot joke it's way way out
and the mvp drains the long three
then we get a tape measure company right
here to
look at that i mean that's about six or
seven feet below or past that
three-point line but as you mentioned
three seconds on the shot clock
wood
jordan's got it
[Applause]
the play in
good challenge actually to get out of
gorham's hand
well you know what i think that's pretty
good i wondered at first
jason tate point blank range
and joking gets it out of there
that's that's a clean block
[Applause]
jokage cutting through extra
great feed to barton who knocks it in
another just absolutely great pass
watch his pass luke fournier comes there
he doesn't even look he's looking dead
towards the rim i thought he was going
to shoot it
but he's looking straight at the rim
just kicks out
a basket would restore order
yokoch in on eubanks
pop it out gordon for three yes
assist nicola joking
jokic with 35 15 and six on the night
[Music]
trying to get the ball in the trolley
why not
sling it left handed into the corner
three is on the way and good a left hand
slinger here at the first quarter the
last two or three weeks in a row watch
this his left hand just
as you said the serbians
yeah sacramento trying to drive in
there's jokic that man again
jokic with the block shot is second
tonight oh
i want to pass my yoke
oh look away as good as it gets
watch him he's looking at will bart
right there
[Applause]
oh that is just beautiful that's
probably really easy for nicola yokic
but any other human being on the planet
earth that is a toughy
pretty good for a power forward but
you're absolutely right
13 left in the half that's a deep one oh
hello steph curry you watching
good drive from will barton challenging
the defense and nicole yokic rotates
over
from the ball arena logo
steven adams
trying to get a piece of it nicolio
i don't know his down here is going to
be what can he do there
come on now joker over the shoulder to
will the thrill
the other one did they're going to
review it
either way the ball was stopped look at
that pass just over the back and
those pants even prettier because now
[Applause]
you finish it with the dunk on top of it
ciaco
over to van blade that's no good rebound
on the weekends
not tonight buddy it is 350 career
blocks this is one of the greatest
blocks
of the 350. that might be one of his
best ever
how about a game saver
and that's a layup for anna nobi
gordon is guarding pool
anderson is off the mark and yokota
11th board for joker
oh what a pass and the layup is perfect
what a pass
as he usually is he's trying to push the
pace get him to get that energy and look
at that pass the foul shooting has been
very very poor they've missed four or
five in his hand
hardin misses that oh there it is
and there's the unbelievable
passing ability of nicola jocas
tobias harris
nice shot in the paint good look
wouldn't go you'll catch a break look at
this guy oh what a pass and green throws
it down
nicola yokoch with a spectacular resist
last six minutes of that quarter they
got what they wanted a shot and a miss
opened up the transition game